hey guys how's it going today we're
going to be doing a super super exciting
video I was damned robbed of your
official title that you give yourself
you can feel tired I mean you've done so
many food reviews of pretty much
everything pretty much you my favorite
right now of all my reviews fat burger
now tops what five guys used to be real
it has destroyed the Five Guys burger
the best burger I've ever had since
YouTube well today we're actually going
to be making a cheeseburger and french
fries
how do you feel I feel like I mean are
you are you ready for that I don't know
you ever made them before
no no seven do a little cooking like
once close to never do you make burgers
mmm I need one one and I got I didn't
have it well it's good but it's very
chewy is the cooking basic you cook with
maybe through okay let me go get the
ingredients and I will be right back I
don't have never made a burger like this
before
oh you want to give me the rad cooler
burger
yeah yummy love it yeah
kitchen magic best ever burger maker
tastes like a real burger and fries so
you know something about well burger and
fries names like I've seen tons of your
reviews pretty much all across
everywhere so we're going to find out if
this actually don't taste like a burger
no which I have my reserved but uh let's
find out let's find out how close to
burgers and fries yummy nummies comes
look excited with this one all wrong
we'll just open it up yeah yeah we gonna
get right into that that's that's crazy
Oh doing like oh I'm not coming a little
happy mailbox what was that all about
because it's for children do not watch
this what we doing for the cash this is
poison okay my finger my pinky is bigger
than the utensils they provide that's
incredible
okay oh wait hold on Tom Oh what why do
we have packets it is hot couple need to
know this is where the meat is
and the bread we're also making a book
like why through the box but they're
like a little soda we're going to make
as well no but burger should make this
out ever
oh my gosh your burger that's your soda
pop this is the bun this is your ketchup
this is your burger and here's your
fries my burger is still making the
powder sound I was in backup because you
just already look hot stop with the
yummy number you keep going tray 1 we
need to mix together three round scoops
of powder with three square scoops of
what oh this is difficult
this is we've got three measurements
today what is nice vanilla try to make
oh yeah oh gosh that take the subway
wait have to the wall I guess I was
trying to give it a little of you got a
hostile
oh I don't come up with my Dennis three
round scoop okay
the vibe mixture evenly into trays 57
and also get three square scoops of
water
yeah yeah yeah okay I mean I would have
preferred for us to do something out of
Easy Bake Oven
I would I want to do some Easy Bake Oven
out of what this is this is incredible
I've already done that tiny many pieces
with my sister and then ro and I just
did one it is a tiny chicken movie I
didn't want to talk about the stuffing
oh okay go ahead yeah but then I know
all the said it looks like oatmeal hmm
this is supposed to be big
you bought mix it you got to mix it real
good and you ever done this before
no you think you going again now we
create our be insufficient set you know
I read the directions then I forget what
this day I don't know how children do
things open doesn't do this I think they
forgot it Oh
oh my goodness this is raw love so many
levels
yeah and I'm not going difficulty with
you on that one
you've got me over here just creating
like baby burgers chemical kid burgers a
baby Burke Thank You Garber burgers over
food it really is okay well now we got
to make our bun okay here you go
tray to five round scoops of powder this
should have as much Mountain three
square scoops of water yes okay one two
three
this crazy
disgusting this is a bun we sort of
molded afterwards oh yeah shape it into
the blood mm-hmm there it is that's our
bun both I mean I am feeling if we were
making real burgers that it probably
would be even worse
this looks like ticky-tack like you with
it hang like a painting or something
with all right there goes our sticky bun
now we microwave the burgers of buns
tray okay here you go
three round and tray for Oh does
actually have a stand to it I'm smelling
something
oh it smells like burning plastic cats
we're through the water looks good you
know no it does it does not got enough
water me if that happens good we know
give it a little more can adjust that go
on oh yeah this will work for you oh I
don't even think that's won't have it
the cab job oh no you know mess of the
cheshire game do you wanna have people
put on two two and a half four three
squares nips of water yeah look at this
it just was like ketchup too you know Oh
God oh my complete now we're gonna make
our french fries one two you see my
french fries come on don't like this
only I may like hash browns before four
square scoops of water has to been there
that's what I've been there Sarge you
actually take it out mixing bowls and
everything mix up to the yummies over
here that's up crazy
we need this to be good
to 304 I don't
sure Gerber Gerber products although
complete so they have a thing to make
soda but probably going to be really do
let's try it filled a cup of water
oh wow this book XY let's look at all
wrong you look like regular ground ok it
looks like it to get cut this little bad
guys
oh wow - good job mix and skip this in
here to make our little fry this
probably looks like the most appetizing
you want make our soda oh all right
there you go one ounce to go global in
the ground I'm gonna work on a cheese
here just want more fries oh yes
definitely
well I
okay here we go
don't hit the cup of art oh because this
is rockin this encompasses chocolate
after whomp you can use our knife lot of
biggest knife look at that
oh my actual bread because I need to cut
yourself short rubber thank you
[Music]
- okay cheese on your fries incredible
this is what you can happen to watch no
no that's not at all no what do you
think the worst thing is you've ever
like been a taste test of besides
potentially this subway full court Haley
oh my I think I let me do the honors for
you happen to it it's a little party
burger burger in there I'm gonna fry in
first we'll try a forever
oh yeah that's definitely is some solid
ketchup oh Lord
crawl yeah this is it this is that are
you ready all right okay good just doing
it not bad but it's just not good
correct
ah it's not horrible right you can't
really expect much from a baby oh
yeah set your expectations low yeah so
you have to say you have your
expectations on Dermer and once you do
that and know that this is like one step
up from girl before you hit like
Lunchables you know they're like you're
the middle right here it depends for
once well you all said you open Garber
to this that you hit luggable don't mean
so this is that mid-level frogs all
right yeah bear bear okay no fun with a
badger I think I'm gonna skip on that
because it basically just is like jelly
okay ready here we go
I am sure gonna like him I don't go
gummy no white of electable drink yeah I
want you beat 45 million to have a full
meal you knock yourself off ketchup
I love football oh my god
you're delicious what more power to you
for being well chance well because it
takes time that's the type of champion
to do what you just did
it's all his advocates of death I had
the fourteenth of death and had the
preparation look of death it was bad all
around Oh God oh my goodness daddy super
hot you could have just stopped family I
didn't think it was into that bad like
the half a bite was fine you dipped in
that get done ketchup besides our
kingdom from hey let's play tell her
anyway no no I haven't eat plenty no
White House this tastes like right off
which was trained addictions is when you
cook bang I was like three what does it
taste like
it was like a salty spin all right right
the which we give it like a rating or
something yes overall I'm gonna have to
go with a negative - boo boo the fool
you know if you know my rating system
you guys usually hide you're down with
something a little more than
questionable so this is a little more
than questionable it's it's visa for
nobody
for nobody sees it for nobody but it's
good to put together you know if you
want to take pictures is great for
pictures yeah and if you're you know 6
and older it's perfect because that's
the age range and so to play with yeah
great what had a good time thank you so
much and now we're off to go do another
food review in your channel yes we're
not sure what it's going to be because
we're not sure of the place that we plan
on
that meeting there and if it is we're
going to all Caesars and it was a small
creature but if it is not there that
we're going to have to go to Jimmy John
so that's what we're going to go we'll
be one of the other that you are see man
I just did over here on my channel
what we channel and where can we find
you guys all right so on YouTube I am
Dame dropped vay mdro PS and of course
you can hit me on all my social media
Twitter add game drops Instagram
official game drops but most important
right right here all right thank you
guys I'm going to go um what do I throw
up and throw this away where does it
provide the try to soda do that Oh
[Music]
champion oh god i oh god I mean it not
hey guys how's it going it's 15 and
today we're going to be talking about
the past weeks that I've spent with a
Nintendo switch and I'm not going to lie
it's actually exceeded my expectation
but at end of sent out a bunch of early
copies to youtubers and journalists as
usual as most game companies do and I'm
so grateful that they did send me one
but you go and go to the unboxing and
also a set up video if you guys haven't
seen that you can feel free to